okay hello everyone i'm dorothy static
uh and i am one of the co-instructors of
cs221 and uh today i'm here with percy
liang and our group of
tas here to teach uh the first lecture
of 221
so with that i would like to first
before getting started in the details of
the class just introduce uh the team so
i am dorothy sadik i am an assistant
professor in computer science
uh and i this is the fifth time i'm
teaching cs221
uh the second time i'm teaching it
online virtually uh i think it is the
third time i'm co-teaching with percy
liang so really excited uh to to start
the quarter with you guys here and and
my research just a little bit about my
research my work is on the
in robotics and ai and in general very
interested in the interaction between
robotics and ai agents with humans and
with other agents other intelligent
agents so if these topics are of
interest come to office hours we'd love
to chat about that and talk about it
offline in general too
uh my co-instructor today here is percy
liang i think i saw percy uh somewhere
yeah i'm here
hello everyone i'm percy i'm the
co-instructor um and i think this is my
ninth or tenth year teaching 221 it's
really been interesting how ai has
evolved since since when i first started
talking
about it
my research interests are in machine
learning and natural language processing
thinking about how to make systems more
robust and
trustworthy
recently i've been really fascinated by
what we've been calling foundation
models uh models such as gp3 and bert
and dali
and i'm going to discuss that more later
in the class
all right
thank you percy
all right so um so what are we going to
be talking about today so our plan for
today is to talk a little bit about some
of the course logistics and then some of
the course contents like what are we
going to actually cover as part of this
class then we'll have some icebreakers
so we'll have like a five minute
breakout room we'll discuss things about
ai and then toward the end of the class
i'm going to talk a little bit about the
history of a brief history of ai and
then what ai is today and what are some
risks and benefits of ai and how we
should think about it moving forward so
so that is our plan for today okay so
before i start also if there are any
questions um
feel free to put questions on on zoom
chat and or raise your hand and the ca
skin and can try to um kind of like
answer the questions or like ask the
questions like throughout um as a as i
give as i give the talk
all right so so let's talk about course
logistics
so
so we're going to have a set of
activities as part of the class and and
last year when we had to go virtually
because of because of covet we started
experimenting with a few different ways
of changing and reformatting the class
and some of them worked really well and
some of them actually didn't work so
well so based on the experience that we
have from last year we've decided to
switch up the activities a little bit
more and also like some of some of these
some of these changes really make sense
to do also throughout like normal
quarter to even if
even if you're not virtual so so one of
these changes is going from traditional
lectures to something that you're
calling modules so these are basically
pre-recorded modules and lectures that
are that are broken into small
bite-sized chunks so so on every topic
that we are we are going to cover in
this class we're going to have a lecture
of like 10 to 20 minutes and a module
really that goes over that topic and
these are pre-recorded and you're going
to release these like the modules for
that week on the monday of the week so
you have time to to watch these kind of
like
based on your own schedule and when it
makes sense for you to watch these
lectures so it's a little bit easier to
manage these like bite-sized chunks
that's one reason that you're going
towards these modules also these are
pre-recorded and you're probably going
to use the same recordings as as last
year so so um so we have more time to
spend with you guys during our lecture
times uh kind of in a flipped format
okay
so so that's the modules
then in addition to that during our
normal lecture time you're going to have
two types of activities so on mondays
you're going to have faculty chats so
these are going to be unzoom and they're
basically small group discussions with
faculty on on ai related topics so um
they're going to be basically six like
25 minute sessions so so every monday
from from 1 30 to 3 p.m uh percy and i
each of us are going to have a zoom room
like 30 minutes each for each session
and you're going to be assigned for one
of these faculty chats so this is
actually mandatory to attend at least
like one of these faculty chats and the
reason we are doing this is
traditionally when you have a large ai
course like you have like 300 something
enrollment and it's really hard to get
to know you guys and actually like talk
to you and sometimes it becomes like
really difficult to know the faculty
when you're in some of these larger
classes and this is really like what
what we are trying what we're trying to
do here is is really to to get to know
you through some of these faculty chats
and discuss like some of the ai related
topics some of the some of the more
recent material research material around
newer topics like foundation models that
percy is going to talk about or some of
the some of the topics around robotics
autonomous driving and so on
so i'll talk about this a little bit
later in the talk the exact format of it
and and and there is a little bit of a
homework to do beforehand before coming
to
to these
sessions but but the idea is we'll have
these in pers not in person sorry
virtual virtual faculty chats on mondays
and lecture time and one other point
that i want to mention is that if you
have conflicts during lecture times you
want to make sure that you wouldn't have
conflict for the time that you're you're
assigned so it does actually because
that is mandatory so make sure that you
actually don't have conflicts during
lecture times
all right
so um the second uh bit is problem
session so this is going to be on
wednesdays so on wednesdays again during
class time you're going to have these
problem sessions and they're kind of
like traditional sections except for we
have changed them a little bit based on
that based on the feedback that we got
last year and during these problem
sessions we're going to have the cas
work out practice problems so these
could be previous years quizzes or
previous years exam questions or
basically just problems that can help
you get started on your homework or or
basically get ready for for some of some
of the exam questions later on so so i
do recommend going to these problem
sessions they're incredibly useful to to
get your hands dirty with some of the
topics that that you're learning that
week and again this is on zoom
on wednesdays class time
all right so what else we're going to
also have um homework parties so
homework parties uh used to be very
popular when they were in person and
last year i think it was a little bit
more difficult to make it happen but
eventually people realize that homework
parties like matter a lot because that's
a very good place to show up and and and
work with other people on your homework
problems get started on on on some of
some of the more challenging problems
together study together and the cas will
be there to answer questions so these
homework parties are going to happen on
nukes which is a platform that we
started using last year again all the
information about zoom nukes like all
these all these links are is on the
cs221 website so so the details of all
everything i say today is also on the
website okay
all right so beyond homework parties we
also have office hours so the cas have
office hours and there are two types of
office hours so um there there are a set
of in-person office hours that i was
talking about earlier these are limited
but they're going to be in the basement
of hwang and and they are group based
there's no sign up required but but
basically there's a group of students
and the ca at a at the basement of huang
in addition to that we also the majority
of office hours are actually going to be
virtual and these are by appointments so
so we used calendar last year and part
of it was just these queues were
becoming too long to handle so now we
you have you can make it and make an
appointment for ca office hour it's
going to be a one-on-one office hour and
these office hours will happen on weeks
okay
in addition our ca office hours are two
categories so we have separated general
office hours from homework office hours
so if you have over questions you should
just go to the dedicated homework office
hours but if you have more general
questions about the course if you're
thinking about your project if you're
thinking about general ai questions you
should go to the general office hours or
the faculty office hours
all right so um and then the final thing
that we have is faculty office hours so
so percy and i both of us will have a
50-minute office hours weekly and the
schedule for this is also uh on on on
the website so you can take a look at
that again it's one on one it is going
to be virtual um and um you can sign up
for them beforehand and come and chat
with us and again all details is on the
website
all right so let me just like see if
there are any questions here
does that
anyone have any questions
should i look at chat okay let me just
quickly look at chat uh so many of you
know each faculty chat to attend so we
will be in touch about this soon so
actually on that there is um i'll talk
about this in a little bit but uh
basically uh there's a survey that you
need to fill out uh by i should notice
by wednesday correct me if i'm wrong by
wednesday
no wednesday
okay by wednesday yeah so that is
basically to get your preferences on um
on what faculty chat you would like to
go and then we'll also assign you after
that to specific faculty chats okay
all right
uh do we sign up for ca and faculty
office hours through nukes so no we will
use calendar for signing up but we'll
use nukes for for answering questions
all right
okay
all right so if there are not
no more questions let me go to the next
slide so so now let's talk a little bit
about periodics so so this is a question
that oftentimes comes up
so what are the prereqs for the class so
you need to have some programming
background uh it would be good if it is
in python so so these are some courses
that are prereqs for this course in
addition to that it's a good idea to
have some mathematic math backgrounds so
discrete math cs10103
is is a
is a prereq in addition to that it would
be a good idea to have some background
in probability and linear algebra so 109
and math math 51. okay
but but in general we want you guys to
have general familiarity with these
and have some mathematical rigor and
general familiarity with probability
linearity of our discrete math these
types of topics we are not really
expecting a very specific type of
knowledge for example like in linear
algebra you'll learn about eigenvectors
but like we don't really like require
the knowledge of eigenvectors in this
class so so they're not specific topics
that we're looking for but generally you
want to know math you want to know
programming and and come into class with
that knowledge and and the reason is
that this course is also fairly like
fast-paced so you don't want to spend
your time like learning python or
learning learning math through this
class your your python programming and
programming is going to improve your
math knowledge is going to improve but
you don't want to spend time learning
these backgrounds and you want to really
spend all of your time learning ai so so
if there are gaps some people do catch
up it is possible but again you want to
spend your time like learning ai so you
kind of like leave it to you guys to
decide and then and move forward and and
you might ask okay how do i decide so we
have a we have a couple of things online
that you can take a look at so so we
have a set of modules that we recorded
actually last year and and these are
prereq modules so these kind of provide
refreshers of some of these topics so
definitely take a look at some of these
prereq modules and that gives you a kind
of like a good sense of what is required
to know to come into this class
in addition to that the first homework
is based on foundations and the first
homework really gives you a good idea of
what to expect as part of this class in
terms of again programming and math
knowledge coming in so take a look at
these before deciding if you want to
skip every wreck or not but in general
again i do think it's a good idea to
have these backgrounds coming into this
class
all right
so let's then talk about grading a
little bit so grading is fairly
straightforward so so we're going to
have a set of homeworks um that's 55 of
the grade we're going to have two exams
so that is 40 of the grade uh the
faculty chats we actually count
participation part as part of the grade
so that is five percent and then
projects we are going to make that uh
optional this year so it's going to
count down towards extra credit and then
if you contribute to ed so we're going
to use at this quarter as opposed to
piata if you contribute to ed that is
also going to give you some level of
extra credit okay
uh and in general you can take the class
uh for letter grade or pass no pass that
is also like your choice basically so
now let's talk about each one of these
components a little bit in more detail
so um
so in terms of homeworks we have eight
homeworks and these eight homeworks are
a mix of programming questions and
written questions and the programming
problems are mainly focused on a
specific application so uh like for
example we might be looking at uh
blackjack as a game or we might be
looking at like pac-man as a game of
pac-man or various types of topics like
car tracking so so there's a particular
application that is used as part of the
programming component of the homeworks
and these programming components they're
auto-graded so
and then there are a set of basically
public and private tests so you should
definitely try out these public tests
first make sure that you you test this
thoroughly because the grading is very
strict it's based on auto grading and
you don't see all the tests so that's
kind of like the point that i was trying
to make here
uh and then um in addition to that you
have seven total late states and you can
use maximum of two per homework the
reason for that is you want to release
the homework solutions so you can't use
more than two late days for homeworks
okay so so that is homeworks okay so
that's our plan for homeworks the usual
we'll go with that
um
one other point that i want to add on
homeworks is we are adding an extra
addition to every every single homework
which is an ethics component so it's an
ethics component is going to be added uh
to all of our homeworks is a new edition
that you're having this quarter and
we're also going to significantly change
some of these homeworks uh to
incorporate an ethics question into them
so so we're trying to incorporate that
throughout the class throughout these
homeworks so uh that would be that would
be also an addition to consider this
course all right so moving forward with
exams so um this quarter last year we
decided to do a set of quizzes this year
we're not going to do the quizzes that
didn't really like students don't really
like it every every week so instead we
were going to have two exams okay
and and the point of the exams is really
to test the ability of your knowledge on
working in new problems it's not really
to know like facts that you're teaching
it's more about like your knowledge of
ai and if you can actually apply that to
new problems
and and all these problems are going to
be written so no coding and you should
take a look at like past exams to get a
sense of like that like how these
problems look like and and what is a
format of them so each one of the exams
is going to be a hundred minutes and and
these exams are going to be to be open
book
so um we actually have the dates for
these exams already they are going to be
released in a 24 24-hour window uh so
they're going to be released on one of
the first one is going to be released on
october 29th at 3 15 p.m and then it's
going to be due the next day at 3 15 p.m
pacific time and then similarly we have
exam 2 on december 8th since it's 3 15
p.m pacific time is the time okay
all right so um we have these dates if
you have major conflicts about with any
of these dates you should let us know by
october 8th which is week three of the
class okay
uh in addition we will not have any late
days for these exams um again and
because we need to release solutions we
need to make sure it works for everyone
so no late days gets applied to the
exams and of course no collaboration on
the exam so please do not talk about the
exams on x so so like if you've done it
you're done with it but there's still
like time left uh within that 24 hour
window do not post anything about the
exam on on it okay
all right so that was that was exams
um and uh the last component uh that is
mandatory as part of the class is the
faculty chat participation so so as i
was mentioning earlier the goal of this
is really discussing topics around ai
like related and topics around the ai
so fill out this initial survey that i
was talking about by wednesday so so
that way we can start scheduling these
you're going to be a sign in session
again six sessions run in parallel on
mondays
and this is during class time on mondays
so make sure that you can actually make
them make that time
and then
you should prepare before these sessions
and these sessions are going to be on
different topics so if they are on
specific like research topics like
robotics autonomous driving ethics uh
robustness foundation models uh we often
have some related material that that we
released beforehand sometimes these are
we had a set of fireside chats last year
it could be like that fireside chat to
watch and or talks last year
it could be basically that talk to watch
beforehand so you come to the come to
the session a little bit prepared and we
can talk about these topics we also have
another set of topics that are really
about uh more thinking about academia
versus industry graduate school uh
thinking about like how you read a
research paper so
so some of these and other components
that are maybe not necessarily a
particular research area and again
you'll have some material for this
reading material to have beforehand so
you come in again prepared so the way we
are looking at participation as part of
these faculty chats is as you come in
you should introduce yourself and you
should also share a little bit about
your thoughts or your goals for that
session so you should actively
participate in that in that 25 minute
session and you kind of expect that when
you're thinking about participation and
grading participation uh during these
faculty chats okay
uh you will not be tested on the
material that you're discussing on the
faculty chats so i also just wanted to
mention
all right
um do we need to attend one faculty chat
session to get yes so you will be
assigned one to one faculty chat if
there is room you can actually attend
more faculty chats uh we are potentially
going to have more room based on the
number of students who are enrolled but
uh we will be in touch on like what is
like what are the availabilities and if
you can attend more than one faculty
chat but yeah you'll be assigned one
okay so let me talk about uh the project
also real quick so
um the project this quarter is going to
be optional uh this is what we did last
year too because the course is virtual
and we thought it would be um
it might be a little bit more difficult
to to find a team and work together but
regardless like a lot of students did
the project last year and and there are
a lot of interesting ideas and projects
came out of that and it was really
exciting to see like so many cool
projects uh like during that quarter too
so i do recommend that you guys look
into this closely even though it is
optional so so the idea is you want to
choose a task uh where you can actually
apply some of the ideas that you have
learned as part of this class and and
use those techniques for that particular
task it's a little bit open-ended you
need to like decide what that task is
but that's also the beauty of it right
you can pick anything and apply some of
the ai techniques that you're learning
for that
uh the idea is that you can work in
groups of up to four people
and then you also have a set of
[Music]
stones like uh you need to fill out a
project interest form there's a proposal
progress report and there's a video and
final reports that you need to do so if
you decide to do the project and
actually get the extra credit you should
do all these different you should
actually like pass through all these
milestones and finish the project
uh again the task is completely open and
and but but there are a set of
well-defined steps that we expect you
guys to to to have throughout the course
uh throughout the course for this um for
this project
uh so this includes things of the form
of like defining the task or
implementing your baselines and oracles
and things of those form or having a
literature review thinking about what
your revaluation metrics are and and you
will have a ca assigned to you if you
decide to do a project you'll have a ca
assigned to your group and your ca can
also walk you through some of these
different components that that you want
to have as part of your project
and in addition to that one other thing
that we've added is a mandatory check-in
meeting with your ca so this is a
15-minute mandatory check-in meeting
david your ca you think this is really
useful and to make sure that you are you
keep you keep up with the project if you
decide to do it and in general if you
want to think about ideas for what to do
for your project or if you have some
idea and you want to discuss it
definitely come to office hours you can
come to a person at nice office hour or
like the ci's office hours and discuss
discuss some of these questions okay
all right
um and the last point that i want to
mention on
honor
on logistics is the honor code so i want
to spend a little bit of time talking
about this because this is really
important you guys don't want to deal
with it we don't want to deal with it so
let's just talk about it and
get it out of the way so
especially this quarter given that
things are online we do want you guys to
collaborate we do want you guys to
discuss together learn together like
think about problems together but the
write up and the code needs to be
entered independently so so you need to
like write your code you need to write
up your solutions like independently
based on your own thoughts and your own
ideas so please do not sure code please
do not share your write-ups with others
and don't look at anyone else's write-up
or code even if it is on internet and
you found it but not look at these
things
um and then um yeah do not post it
online but like if you're proud of your
code you shouldn't post it on github do
not do that
um and and in general when you're
debugging try to look at like input
output behavior you could be like going
to homework parties and debugging your
solutions with other people and really
just look at input output behavior don't
look at each other's code and and that
way you'll be safe
but i do want to emphasize that we do
run moss periodically and this will
automatically like detect like if there
is like matching between codes and and
please like do not do that in boss is
really good uh so
yeah so and every year we have a number
of cases and sometimes like we run these
things mid-quarter so i want to also
emphasize that and then you don't want
to you don't want to want
things like yeah you don't want to go
through these things like mid-quarter
and and it's it's again something that
we don't want to deal with we don't want
to deal with let's just not do it you're
also changing a number of like homework
questions and you're adding like you're
adapting things to make this a little
bit easier on everyone
all right oh and then the last point i
want to make is on communication so um
we're going to use ed this quarter so in
general if you have any questions best
idea is to
put it public at the post that way of
course staff students everyone can see
it and you have a broader group of
people who can answer that question and
you can hope like probably other people
are thinking about that question too so
that's kind of a best way of
communicating with us if there is a
private question make a private ad post
and that way the course staff can see it
uh and and for example if you have a
question uh that can give away answers
it's a good idea to to post that as a
private post and in general if there are
sensitive matters that you want to
discuss or oe accommodations you should
email the court uh the the this
particular email address this goes to
only four people this goes to percy and
i and shiri and faith so our student
liaison and our head ca so if you have
any sensitive matter you should just uh
send an email to this email list that
goes to the four of us
um in addition to that you're going to
have periodic surveys you also have a
welcome survey already on canvas so so
please take a look at that and fill that
up and and that way we can start getting
getting some feedback and again as the
course is virtual we would love to get
more feedback periodic feedback
throughout the course so it will be
great to give us feedback tell us what
works what doesn't work so we can
adapt and again all these details
everything i've said so far
is on the course website
and and with that i can take any
questions about logistics i know i
covered quite a bit on logistics
if anyone wants to just ask a question
that's probably easier to because then
so
if uh so on the exam if we're looking
for a clarification should we post that
privately to ad not at all or should we
email it
assuming that it's not something that
was supposed to give anything away it's
just supposed to be a clarification of
what's intended by the question
you should you should post a private
private post on end that only go to
their courses
that was a good guideline but then uh as
far as with the coding of
python um what about uh the use you know
in terms of basic routines obviously not
uh trying to copy uh
codes wholesale but
as far as using things like stack
overflow and
and others as far as four
um obviously there's all the various uh
things that can be used as sort of like
uh you know uh virtual to tutorials and
uh you know various things that you
wanna accomplish with the python that
you're writing
i assume that
as long as it's you know just little
uh routines that it's not a problem it's
the problem is when it's starting to be
that you're
taking somebody's idea
wholesale yeah and in general yeah so
try to write things like yeah yourself
basically like when it comes to writing
the code part of it try to like you can
get ideas you can discuss the idea of it
with other people or you can like yeah
like look at like online forms for ideas
but when it comes to writing the code uh
try to just write it yourself if there
are specific like things that you're not
sure of like you should go to the ca
office hours or should go to our office
hours basically ask us like that
specific instance and uh we can talk
about it then yeah
okay
all right so let's move forward uh so
now let's talk a little bit about the
course content okay
so what are we discussing what is ai
what are we going to be covering in this
class
so so in general you're an ai right like
you're interested in solving realistic
complex problems that have a lot of
messiness and uncertainty and if you
think about a complex problem let's say
routing cars like in a city with a lot
of like complex settings that is
happening in that city how do you how do
you go about solving that question let's
say the question is just routing the
vehicles right like you're not going to
start just writing out code for it right
like you're going don't start from
scratch and from like not really having
a formal exam to just directly code that
that seems pretty difficult and in
general there's there's a gap between
the code or the software the hardware
that in general we developed as ai
scientists as engineers and what is
happening in reality like what is the
real world with messy with all the messy
and complex messiness and complexities
that exist
and then really what ai and what in this
course is trying to do is to bridge that
gap to figure out how we can take some
of these real world problems and and
make it simpler in a way that is
manageable so we can develop algorithms
and code for it
and for that we have a paradigm in this
class that would like to follow and this
paradigm has three different core
components three pillars and these three
pillars are the modeling in friends and
learning pillars and i'm going to talk a
little bit about these so so the idea is
we take a very difficult problem we
model it and then we develop inference
algorithms for it and then throughout
the this process
there could also be the model could have
a set of unknowns and we use learning
throughout to actually make our models
better so so let me let me try to make
this a little bit more clear moving
forward so so let's go back to this real
world problem that you were talking
about droughting vehicles like on in a
city okay so so this is a this is a big
problem and in general i would like to
have a formalism so what modeling does
is it takes that complex problem and it
tries to come up with a formalism with a
mathematical way of thinking about that
problem and and modeling just by
definition is lossy right like i'm not
gonna get all that complexity that
exists in the real world right all
models are wrong but some are useful
right so so under that idea of course
you're going to lose some of this
complexity but we're still going to come
up with something that is somewhat
useful for the goal that we have maybe i
would like to find the shortest surest
way of getting from one one road to
another road and if that is my goal i
can basically maybe model this real
world problem as a graph problem where i
have i have a bunch of edges and
vertices and my vertices here are maybe
my locations like in the world and then
the edges are maybe the roads that
connect them okay so this would be a
graph model that represents that real
world problem
so we're going to spend quite a bit of
time in this class talking about
modeling
and then once i have a model then i can
start asking questions about that model
right i can ask for what is the shortest
path of getting from one one node to
another node or what is the most scenic
path of getting getting from one region
to another region or i might have
different objectives that i would like
to be able to optimize and inference is
really a way of trying
to solve that problem and give us an
answer to some of these questions that
that we have here okay so how do we make
predictions how do we figure out what is
the right path to take in in in this
problem is is kind of like the thing
that inference lets us get and then
finally the last pillar is learning and
the way i want you to think of learning
is is that if you think about that model
right like we're oftentimes you're not
gonna write be able to write everything
in in that model with all the
complexities but all we can do is we can
write a skeleton for what we're trying
to do maybe a graph but that graph might
not you might not know what are the edge
like what are the what are the weights
on on the edges like we might not be
given given given the the edge values
here because like that would be like too
complicated to write or we might just
not have it like periods at the
beginning so we often have a model
without parameters and the goal of
learning is to look at data and from
data complete this model and and add
these parameters that were unknown at
the beginning
so so what learning is really doing is
is taking the complexity that we have in
writing the specification writing the
model and and takes that away and puts
that into data and the fact that there
is data i can take that data and then
based on how good that data is or based
on what i can learn from that data i
would be able to complete my model and
have a better model than it can actually
do and friends over so so we're going to
have also learning throughout this class
as a filler in every section that you'll
talk about in this class okay
all right so so modeling inference and
learning are just three pillars that
keep appearing throughout every week of
this class but what is our course plan
so our first plan is really to talk
about different types of models starting
from low-level intelligence all the way
to higher level intelligence
and and we're going to basically go over
a variety of these models but before we
start talking about these we're going to
actually spend two weeks talking about
machine learning so so this is just to
get some of the basics of machine
learning out of also machine learning in
general is a very powerful tool that has
been quite impactful in the field of ai
so so it's a good idea to learn some of
these some of these ideas in machine
learning at the beginning so that we can
actually also use it like throughout the
class when we are thinking about
learning modeling and inference
throughout the class based on these
different types of uh models that we
will discuss throughout throughout okay
so so next next week and the week after
is basically going to be modules and
machine learning
okay um and and um i'm just spending a
little bit time on what is machine
learning so again the role of machine
learning is to take data right and and
from that data try to generate these
models that that were at the beginning
incomplete but now we can actually use
them and then we can actually
incorporate the data the information
that's in that data
in in the model and the idea of it is
really moving from code to data so again
adding
moving the complexity that exists in the
code to complexity existing data and
then one other point about machine
learning is it kind of like it requires
faith right so so if we have some data
based on that data below the model
there's no reason
on the surface that that model could
work in a new scenario that it could
generalize to new settings and then
we'll talk about the idea of
generalization quite a bit like when is
it that the model could generalize to
new settings like if i've trained it on
some set of data of let's say like house
prices how can i make sure that this
model could actually work in a new
setting for a new house and and that
kind of goes back to this question of
generalization and we'll spend time on
that
all right so that was machine learning
so as we were talking about machine
learning in the first two two weeks of
the class we're also going to spend a
little bit of time talking about reflex
based models so these are kind of the
lowest level of intelligence in terms of
in terms of the modeling paradigms that
we'll be talking about throughout the
course
and then example and and here's an
example of a reflex based model so i'm
going to ask you guys what is this
animal
okay
maybe you can put in chat what is this
animal or just like chat
what was it
it was a zebra right and you were very
quickly you were able to quickly figure
out that you just saw a zebra here right
um and and this is really based on your
reflexes this is really like an example
of what a reflex based model could do
other examples of reflex space models
are things of the form of linear
classifiers or deep neural networks and
the idea that i'm calling these like the
reason i'm calling these low intel
low-level intelligence is we're not
making a lot we're not doing a lot of
reasoning here we basically have a feed
forward model and then we're not doing
much computation into responding and
saying well that was a zebra right like
we quickly were just able to quickly say
that that that was a zebra and this
reflect space models they're the most
common form of models in machine
learning they're often like fully feed
forward no backtracking no reasoning
about what was going on and just like
evaluating the model i think
deep neural networks are an example of
this linear classifiers are an example
of this and that that's actually a
reason where we are going to discuss
machine learning we're going to also
spend a little bit time thinking about
reflex space models right
inference is extremely simple and then
we just call the model
all right so moving along uh on top of
the reflex based models the one level
higher we're going to talk about
state-based models
and these state-based models uh we're
going to talk about three types of them
search problems mbps and adversarial
games so so so what are state-based
models so so here is an example let's
say you want to you want to play a game
of chess and you want to figure out
where what should be the next move of
white
so so
this is not the same as detecting if
that if that animal was a zebra this is
actually a lot more difficult than that
you actually need to sit down and do a
little bit of reasoning and figure out
what state in the world you're in and
and figure out like how how the world is
going to evolve so there is kind of like
this notion of like sequences of of
actions and sequence of states that are
coming after each other like a leading
to b and so on and and this kind of
brings us this idea of state-based
models and it hasn't it has many
applications including in in games so if
you think about games like chess go
pac-man starcraft these are these are
all examples uh where we can we can
think about state-based models as a good
way of modeling them
they show up in robotics all the time
you think about motion planning like
getting a robot arm to move from one
location to another location uh we
oftentimes use state-based models as a
way of formalizing that they also show
up in natural language generation
machine translation image captioning
they're basically like all throughout ai
and and they're very good way of
thinking about like what are all the
sufficient information that you need to
know at the current time and how that
should evolve like uh in the next time
step and then adding an ordering of
going from this state to the next state
so so we'll talk about three types of
state-based models we'll talk about
search problems where you can actually
control everything so so you have a
state and then based on the action that
you take you end up in a new state
um we'll talk about markov decision
processes which are making research
problems a little bit more difficult by
adding uncertainty that comes from the
world so so basically these markov
decision processes are state-based
models where you're playing against the
nature right like nature gives you some
probabilities you you would look at like
coin tosses and based on that you
proceed so there is kind of this notion
of uncertainty and then we'll spend some
time talking about games adversarial
games where you're not playing against
nature which is probably
instead you're playing against another
opponent which is also very intelligent
and is making decisions kind of like
against you as opposed to you and then
we'll we'll basically go over these
different types of state-based models uh
a little bit
okay so and as part of the homework for
uh state-based models we're going to
play around with the game of pac-man i
just want to show a quick demo of uh
this game here
yeah so you're going to play around with
the game of pac-man and basically come
up with algorithms for pac-man who can
avoid ghosts and eat these food pellets
and it will be kind of fun playing
around with it and
let me go back to my slides um yeah so
and as you're thinking about pac-man and
general state-based models the things to
think about is what is a notion of
states how should you transit how do you
transition from one state to another uh
how can you come up with a strategy a
policy that can get you from one point
to another so you avoid like the ghosts
and feet your food pilots and so on and
these are some of the questions that
we're going to talk about when we
discuss state-based models
all right so moving forward uh we're
then going to move to the next level of
complexity and intelligence and not
complexity intelligence and that is
variable based models so so an example
of a variable based model is something
like a game of sudoku so if you think
about state-based models there's a
notion of like sequential ordering of
states you have to do a to get to you
have to go through a to get to b right
like if you think about like moving
through a graph to for solving like
shortest path you actually need to like
see city one to two and then after that
ccd2 but there are a set of set of
problems that don't really require that
type of ordering that type of strict
ordering so think of the game of sudoku
right like the game of sudoku you have a
bunch of numbers you want to make sure
that you can fit in like digits of one
through nine in every row and column and
the order that you put in these numbers
that doesn't really matter right like
you can put the nines first or you can
put the ones first and that really
doesn't
matter really brings us this idea of
variable based models where we don't
have this script ordering and because of
that then we can do something that's a
little bit more intelligent and and
helps us come up with better algorithms
in these settings so we will talk about
two types of variable based models uh
we'll talk about uh constraint
satisfaction problems these are settings
when we have hard constraints so uh
sudoku was an example right like you
have a hard constraint you have to
actually fit like one through nine in in
your board or like scheduling type
problems like a person cannot be at two
places at the same time so it actually
has very strong strict relations between
the different variables that exist
but we all in addition to that we have
also bayesian networks that try to take
those hard constraints and make them
soft so there are stock dependencies
when you think about bayesian networks
um like unlike let's say sudoku or
scheduling so so an example is let's say
you want to track an airplane or you
want to track a car right like if you're
tracking your car you might have a set
of sensors on that car and those sensors
are noisy they're not going to give you
the ground truth of where the car is you
also know that your car cannot like
teleport right so so the previous time
step where it was and the current times
the next time step they're related to
each other and based on these different
types of relations of where you're where
the car is and where the car is going to
be and the fact that you have these
noisy sensor readings
you can have these soft dependencies
between these variables and that allows
you to estimate where the car is
and then that's the topic that that
we'll discuss like through uh beijing
network we'll have a homework on this
and that will actually be about tracking
cars that'll be exciting
all right and then finally the last
components that we are going to discuss
is uh going to be uh on logic so so this
would bring us to the highest level of
intelligence
and and for logic like as an instance of
an example that uses logic we can think
of a virtual assistant so think of a
virtual assistant what do you want from
virtual assistant you oftentimes want to
tell it some information give it some
information um and you also want to be
able to ask it some some questions right
um and then expect it to respond and
maybe you would want to use like natural
language as a way of communicating with
this virtual assistant so we actually go
through a virtual assistant example as
part of the homework and logic i want to
show a quick demo of that again here um
let me see
if i can bring this
to the right window let me go to the
let me see if i can bring terminal to
this
ah there you go there you go
okay so this is actually a tool that
we're going to play around with during
the uh during the logic homework um and
uh basically it's a virtual assistant
you can give it information you can ask
it information so let me let me try to
some example let me let me actually give
it some information so i'm going to say
alice is a student
okay
sorry dorset could you zoom in
oh yeah
okay so i told it alice as a student and
it just learned something uh i can ask
it now is
alice
student
what should it say
it says yes right because i just told it
alice's student
i'm going to ask is bob student
um what should it respond
you should probably say i don't know
right because how would it know
i don't know
let me give it some facts i can say
students are people
okay
then i can say alice is not a person
let's see what it says in response to
that
okay it says i don't buy that so it
understands it understands contradiction
so so i i told the students or people i
i showed a generalization and now it's a
contradiction to that and it understands
that
i can say alice is the person let's see
what that says it confirms i already
knew that okay
uh let's give it some more information
alice is from phoenix maybe let's do
that
house is from phoenix
i learned something we can say phoenix
is a hot
city i learned something
i can say cities are places
places
i learned something
let me
actually make this a little bit smaller
so you can see this
okay so if it is uh snowing
then it is cold so i'm gonna teach you
kind of like anything else type of
statement
i'll learn something okay i'm gonna ask
it is it snowing what should you say
oh he doesn't know
okay so it says i don't know okay so i'm
gonna give it more information if a
person is from a hot place
and it is it is cold uh then she's not
happy
okay
so i'm giving it this more complicated
if-then-else type statement
i learned something
i'm gonna ask is it snowing
what would it say
mommy doesn't know right i don't know
let's say alice is happy okay
now i'm gonna ask is it snowing what you
could say
yes it's not snowing okay yeah
so uh yeah so so this was just an
example um that was going over like this
the spiritual assistant and you'll play
around with this virtual assistant and
in the logic module um you will be
thinking about this idea of giving
information asking information and the
logical relationships between them um
and and this will be something that we
will work on so i just want to quickly
show this demo
but one thing to notice here is that
here we were giving these kind of like
heterogeneous information this was very
different from me giving like a millions
of pictures of cats and training in all
natural right like i was giving these
very heterogeneous information and then
the system was able to like reason about
these this information in a very deep
way right like it was making these deep
connections and i could ask these
questions from it and that's very
exciting right like that like being able
to have these types of deep deep
deep interactions between the symbols
that we are providing it
um all right so so that kind of brings
us uh to the end of uh this module where
we are thinking about different types of
different types of states uh state
different types of sorry models and and
as just as a just a quick recap right in
this class we were going to talk about
low low-level intelligence all the way
to high-level intelligence models
reflex-based models state-based models
variable-based models and logic and in
each one of these models we're going to
talk about the usual paradigm that we
have that tries to do modeling so we'll
talk about modeling in each one of these
these settings and then we talk about
inference what are the different
inference algorithms that we can use in
addition to that we talk about learning
right like how can we have data and how
can we how can we learn and improve our
models for each one of these components
so that paradigm keeps showing up
throughout the class basically every
week
all right so now let's uh spend five
minutes and and let's have an icebreaker
so
he's going to put us in
in groups of four uh and then in
breakout rooms and during this five
minutes let's just try to introduce
ourselves to others and and just to
maybe set the stage let's let's have a
question and let's discuss a question
and the question is what is the biggest
benefit of ai and what is the biggest
risk of ai and when you come back try to
like put that on chat and uh we will
discuss and and go from there okay so
let's spend five minutes on
on in brave cat rooms
so it was um good talking to some of you
during the breakout rooms um maybe uh
yeah
so maybe you can uh kind of like put
some of your responses some of the
things that you discussed on chat
um as a way of like just discussing some
of them um
also quick things don't direct message
me on chat i'm like barely looking at
chat so if there are any questions
please ping the cas or email me later on
or with questions on ed
okay
all right so yeah
any
biggest benefits biggest risks anyone
has thoughts
okay
thank you for starting this
improving people's lives tangible
applications
mutual assistance biggest risks ml
fairness ethics
yeah so these are all like great points
um i'm gonna talk about them a little
bit a fifth time but now let's uh let's
continue with the kind of like next
segment where i want to give a little
bit of a history of uh ai here and this
is going to be brief i don't want to go
into too much detail it's not going to
be a complete history uh but i think
it's good idea to talk about this
because it gives a little bit of like
insights in terms of like why we are
where we are today and how things shaped
over time so if you want to give a
history of ai like you can really like
go back to 1950 and 19 1950 alan turing
put out during put out um
his kind of like his landmark paper on
computing machinery and intelligence and
in this paper alan turing asked a
question can machines think okay and he
came up with his answer which was the
imitation game which you might know as
the touring test and then you guys might
be familiar with the turing test the
idea of the turing test is that a
machine can pass a turing test if it is
able to fool a person into thinking that
it's actually a human okay
and and this paper was was really like
foundational like in a sense that it
started allowing us to think about
intelligence a lot more carefully um and
and actually try to formalize that uh in
a in a better way and it
it was kind of like one of the first
words one of the foundational works that
it started thinking about yeah
formalizing this this idea of
intelligence and then we might argue on
if turing test is a good test or not in
terms of measuring intelligence and then
we might have various opinions on that
but that part of it is not really the
part that matters the part of it that
matters is thinking about intelligence
being able to formalize it and one other
thing that alan turin actually i'm
turing actually like uh provided in this
in this paper was this idea of
separating the the question that you're
trying to ask the what from the how like
how are we going to answer this question
right like alan turing came up with this
idea of uh imitation game or or um or
and and basically what what this was
giving us was was this idea of object
specification right this is the thing
that we are trying to get this is our
specification that we are trying to get
at but how we do it or how the machine
really does it but he didn't really
specify that and this modularity of
specifying what we are trying to get and
how we are trying to get that this is
really like a foundational idea that we
have been also using in a lot of our
algorithms and we see throughout this
class like separating out the objective
from the algorithm and how we are going
about it is actually quite important and
then it's a
very good foundational idea um and and
one interesting thing is that touring uh
also provided like at the end of this
paper provided some ideas in terms of
how we should go about it and he talked
about two different approaches one was
this very abstract way of going about
this problem kind of like a top-down
view kind of like how we would go about
solving chess and this is really related
to this idea of symbolic ai that i'm
going to talk about and he also provided
another potential way of going about
this which is like having machines that
have sense organs aka sensors and then
teach them like a child right and then
this idea of teaching a machine and then
getting that machine and have sensors on
it and let it sense data and from that
data try to learn um that that idea is
very related to the idea of neural ai so
so since this point right 19 1950 where
touring put out this paper there has
been kind of like three different
flavors of ai that has been around right
this is there's symbolic ai there's
neural ai and there's statistical ai and
i want to give a little bit of a history
brief history of each one of these so
let's start with in 1956 and let's start
with the the story of symbolic ai so
this is the first type of ai flavor of
ai that i want to talk about so so the
term ai really comes back to to this age
of 1956 and this is when uh mccarthy um
basically organized a workshop and at
dartsmith college so john mccarthy he
was a faculty at stanford cs he actually
uh created the stanford ai lab and and
he organized a workshop at dartmouth
college that summer and he invited a lot
of other big names like marvin minsky
newell um herbert simon
he invited all of these people and the
goal of this workshop was to think about
intelligence right they wanted to they
had a very ambitious goal they wanted to
think about every aspect of learning and
then every feature of intelligence and
they wanted to model that so precisely
so they can have a machine that could
simulate that and this is a very
ambitious goal right and then they were
really after generality they wanted to
figure out what are the general
principles of intelligence and
learning that they can really get so so
they can have an artificial intelligence
and an intelligent agent that can
stimulate that and that was that was
really exciting and immediately after
after this workshop all these people
went back their ways and they started
producing really cool systems around
this time so this was really the birth
of ai and you started seeing a lot of
early successes so like 1952 arthur fami
or arthur samuel put out uh one of these
first checkers programs that was able to
play at the at the level of an amateur
like play checker at the level on
amateur which was really exciting um we
also in addition to that um we had uh in
1955 noah and simon came up with uh the
theorem with kind of our first fear
improvers and and they basically had the
system that could uh that could solve
generally solve problems and solve
theorems they came up with a proof for a
theorem uh that was actually a lot more
elegant than uh than like a per like
than what people had before and they
tried to publish a paper uh on this
proof but the paper got rejected because
the reviewers thought the theorem
already existed but it was really
exciting to be able to have systems that
can prove theorems that can play
checkers that can generally solve
problems
and there are a lot of optimism right
like all these really famous people um
in the in the field
and they all had a lot of optimism about
what is possible with ai right herbert
simon said machines will be capable
within 20 years of doing any work a man
can do marvin minsky said within 10
years the problem of artificial
intelligence will be substantially
solved claude shannon said i visualized
a time when when we will be to robots
with dogs or to humans and i'm rooting
for the machines so these are not like
random people on the street
famous people like founding fathers of
ai and and these are like some of the
optimism overwhelming optimism that
people had around that time what is what
we could actually do with these ai
systems and unfortunately we started
seeing very underwhelming results so
around this time right the government
really cared about the problem machine
translation and there there's a lot of
funding around it and then we started
seeing results that weren't very like
that that weren't
kind of underwhelming and then here is
kind of a made-up example but the
results were things of the form of you
may you might have a text that says the
spirit is willing but the fresh the
flesh is weak and you might translate
that to russian and translate it back to
english and you would get a text that
says the white card is good but the meat
is rotten which is which is very which
is not very good
and as we started seeing these results
right um
like governments started putting out a
report about how these results are are
not are not so great and then they
started cutting off funding for ai
research and this is around the same
time that we started seeing the first
winter of ai so so a lot of optimism
wasn't really going anywhere and we had
this first winter of ai and that wasn't
so great
so if you think about this first early
era of of ai what were some of the
problems so some of the problems were
first off we had very limited
computation like a lot of these problems
were written as logical problems and and
usually like resolved as search problems
where the search space was just growing
exponentially and with the limited
hardware that we had it was just like
not possible to solve these very
difficult problems
but even if we had like infinite compute
at that time which we didn't there was
another problem and this other problem
was the fact that we had limited
information right like if you think
about solving some of these very complex
ai problems that people were thinking
about they they needed to write out
these problems and the knowledge that
exists around them using using words and
objects and writing out the concepts and
then it was very difficult to actually
provide all these information and we had
really limited information about some of
these concepts but regardless we started
seeing a lot of interesting
contributions that came out of this era
even though it was a failure and we had
this
winter of ai there were a lot of
interesting ideas that came out around
this time like we had the list
programming language we had ideas like
garbage collection and time sharing and
a lot of these ideas are associated
actually to john mccarthy but it was
exciting to see a lot of advances even
though like we there were the problems
were still there and we couldn't really
solve the big problem and this really
brings us to the era of 70s and 80s so
in 70s and 80s really uh people started
thinking about this idea of knowledge
and building knowledge based systems and
and and kind of like the core idea was
knowledge is really the key if we can
encode knowledge if you can bring in
ideas from experts and donate like bring
in your domain knowledge and incorporate
that in the system then we can actually
solve interesting ai questions so so
this was the rise of expert systems
where we can basically elicit like
domain specific knowledge from an expert
and encode that into like these if then
else type statements into rules that the
system can call
and be able to like solve various types
of problems
there was also another shift around this
time so so the first era of ai right the
john mccarthy like dartmouth college
like workshop that happened that was all
about understanding intelligence being
able to say well what is human
intelligence and can we stimulate that
and that didn't really work out but in
this new era what happened was people
started kind of like changing and
changing paradigms and they started
thinking about applications a lot more
so sure you're not going to be able to
think about intelligence and simulating
intelligence but i can build systems
that can be used in chemistry or they
can be used in medical diagnosis or they
could be used in business and then this
was kind of like the first era that
people started building ai systems that
maybe they learned so much about
simulating intelligence but they were
they were about solving interesting
useful problems that could be used in
industry
so um lots of events during this time
right so so these knowledge-based
systems they really helped us uh with
both the information and computation gap
right they allowed us to like
incorporate knowledge and information
and by doing so they allowed us to kind
of like prune the search space and that
would help us need like less compute to
solve some of these problems so that was
exciting and this was the first time
that we were seeing some of these real
applications that actually impacted
industry and that was also a lot that
was also very exciting
but there were still some problems
around this era one of the problems was
these rules were very deterministic and
they couldn't really handle the
uncertainty that existed in real world
we had all these deterministic
connections and rules that were never
coming together and they weren't really
capturing the complexity of that that
exists in the world
in addition to that the rules were
becoming very complex very quickly so so
this is a quote from terry vinograd who
was a faculty and hci um in cs
department in hci at stanford and at the
time he was faculty actually and working
in ai at mit and and here's here is some
codes that he said around these
knowledge-based systems he said well
these systems are a dead end and they
have very complex interactions that are
that are difficult to handle and they're
just really no easy footholds to have
and and this really brings us to the
second winter of ai so lots of
excitement right we're seeing real
applications but there was still quite a
bit of difficulty into extending these
systems
and and this was kind of the end of like
this era of symbolic ai right symbolic
ai really dominated ai for many decades
and then and i i now want to go back in
time right like i'm now in 1987 but now
i want to go back in time and tell you a
little bit of a history of neural ai and
where that started and what was what was
kind of um
the progression of that and that takes
us to 1943. so
going back in time
let's think about okay artificial neural
networks and how they started so so in
1943 mccullough and pitts they they came
up with the first artificial neural
network where they had a single neuron
and they basically modeled that's that
single neuron with that and they they
thought about very similar relations
like ants and nerves and and they
weren't thinking about learning rules or
anything of that form at that point and
then that is kind of like 1943 the very
first version of artificial neural
networks and in 1949 help came up with
the idea of coming up with a learning
rule here this learning rule was very
simple it was cells that fire together
wire together and this learning rule it
was actually kind of like it didn't
really work and it wasn't very unstable
but it was one of the first learning
rules that was put in place
and finally in 1958 you started seeing
some advances in artificial neural
networks this is when rosenblatt came up
with the perceptron algorithm for a
single layer neural network which is
basically a linear classifier and this
perceptron algorithm was even been like
was was being used until very recently
and it showed a lot of success it was
actually very powerful and there was a
lot of excitement around it
um 1959 we started seeing the analog of
linear regression that was adeline there
was a multi-layer extension of that
madeline and and this was actually used
for removing echoes on phone lines and
this was again one of the very first
times that people started using
artificial neural networks for for a
real application like removing echoes
from a phone line
and in 1969 that was an important year
for artificial neural networks so so
this year minsky and packard wrote a
book on artificial neural networks they
wrote a book called perceptrons and they
basically tried to analyze mathematical
properties of linear models and the
thing that they showed was actually
something that was very simple which is
a single layer neural network is a
linear classifier it's actually not
going to be able to solve the function
of x or and then this this book is
really associated uh to shutting down
the research on artificial neural
networks so that was a time that people
started thinking maybe maybe um
these types of artificial neural
networks are not very powerful and maybe
we should stop doing research on them
even though the book wasn't really any
saying anything about these neural
networks
regardless um they started seeing a
revival of neural networks and and
around 1980s and this was kind of with
the rise of convolutional neural
networks and the idea like this came
under the umbrella connectionism
and you started seeing that this very
very first convolutional neural networks
and the training of them was very ad hoc
uh but but in 1986 that was kind of
around the time that we started seeing
better training and giving like more
principled ways of training these
systems so uh so uh around this time
rama hart hinton and and williams they
popularized or kind of like reinvented
the idea of back propagation and then
that was adding a lot more principle
into how we should train these systems
and 1989 again that was like one of the
first times that you started seeing
these systems being used in practice so
john le [ __ ] applied commercial neural
networks for recognizing handwritten
digits and he actually deployed this
with usps for detecting digits of zip
codes which was really exciting
but still this idea of artificial neural
networks it was still like a niche like
it wasn't like a thing that everyone was
working on and and that was until like
the era of like deep learning and the
2000 2010s like era so and part of the
reason was it was actually really
difficult to train these models but in
2006 hinton and all they developed the
system an unsupervised layer-wise
pre-training system that was helping
pre-training some of these some of these
neural networks and kind of reducing the
efforts that goes into into training the
disease models but the break really
happened around 2000 so 2012 we started
seeing systems like alex said that were
giving us huge gains in terms of object
recognition like these systems basically
[Music]
revolutionize and transform the field of
computer vision overnight right the type
of the computer vision course that i
took in 2012 was actually pre-neural
networks and it was very different from
like what is being taught today and and
this basically changed the field like
overnight with with the rise of uh
commercial neural networks and training
these systems and being able to do
object recognition
and uh finally in 2016 also we started
seeing um things like alphago like
another breakthrough and and alphago um
was basically using deep reinforcement
learning to defeat like world champion
go player um and that was another
breakthrough that that was that was a
game that people were not thinking we're
thinking it was a lot more difficult and
it was really exciting to see deep
learning and deep reinforcement learning
is able to solve some of these problems
so all right so let me try to wrap up
because i know it's almost 3 p.m and and
we'll release um modules on some of the
rest of the rest of the lecture uh later
today uh but let me just give you some
some kind of like food for thoughts i've
talked about symbolically i have talked
about numeral ai the symbolic ai is
really this top-down view that that is
that goes back its roots goes back
really to logic right like you had these
very big goals of building a virtual
assistant and neural ai on the other
hand it's more like bottom up it's
trying to solve these perceptual tasks
and um and the two like might seem like
might seem to have very philosophical
differences and there's they might seem
contradictory but they're actually not
very contradictory like there are a lot
of deeper connections between them and
today actually people are thinking about
integrating them in ways that that we
weren't able to do before and even if
you go back to the history of it right
like what mccullough and were doing with
the first neural network was was
actually analyzing properties of a
logical system or alphago if you think
about alphago it's a very logical game
that you write like the the the rules of
the game in logic and and it's using
it's using neural networks to solve that
game so there are deeper connections
between these two between between uh
these two views of ai and they really
come together
um all right so um
sorry for going over a little bit uh
what is left as part of this lecture is
really talking talking a little bit
about statistical ai um we'll release
modules on these um and then thinking
about where statistical ai is coming
into play and and wrapping up the
history of ai and then the other part
that is really left in is talking about
ai and what are some risks and benefits
of that and that's something that you
guys talked a little bit about during
the breakout rooms uh but we'll also
talk about that in lecture so if you
want to watch these lectures uh later
that would be cool and
with that
i can
if there are any questions i can take
any questions otherwise i'll see you
guys
next week
you